For the second one, you need to type in the nthroot and a space. This will
create this radical symbol. Your cursor bar will appear here, and you'll need
to hit the Right Arrow key and then type in 5 to get what's underneath the
radical. These would be the keystrokes for our third expression. Notice that
after we type in the square root symbol, we don't need to hit the Right Arrow
key. That's because the index for this root is assumed to be a 2, It's rare
that you'll ever see it, but we know it's a square root. That's why it's a 2.
Math Quill knows it's 2, and so you're just placed back inside the radical. And
then you can type in 21. Now for this last expression, you might not have any
idea what i is. That's okay. We're going to cover this later. To start this
expression, I would type in a forward slash. This would create an entire
fraction with a spot for a numerator and the denominator. We type in these
keystrokes in order to get our entire numerator. And notice that our cursor bar
is here. Once we type in the 6, our cursor bar will appear here, and then we
hit the Right Arrow key twice in order to move it down to the denominator.
Then, we just type a 4 to wrap up our expression. Now, there are other ways
that you can have done this to recreate the fraction bar. You could've created
the fraction bar after the 6. But that means, this forward slash would go in
between these 2 errors. After you type the 6, you're still inside the radical.
So, if you type the forward slash here, you'll create a fraction within the
radical. You don't want that to happen, so you hit the Right Arrow key once.
Which moves the cursor bar outside of the radical, and then you can type a
forward slash to create your fraction, hit the Right Arrow key again to move to
the denominator and then enter 4 to finish up. Either way you do this last one
is correct, I just want you to get comfortable using math quill.